let me ask about power
so uh building super intelligence
systems even if it's not in the near
term I think meta as is one of the few
companies if not the main company that
will develop the super intelligence
system and you are a man who is at the
head of this company building AGI might
make you the most powerful man in the
world do you worry that that power will
corrupt you
what a question
um
I mean look I think realistically this
gets back to the open source things that
we talked about before which is I don't
think that the world will be best served
by
any small number of organizations
having this
without it being something that is more
broadly available I think if you look
through history
it's when there are these sort of like
unipolar advances and things that in
like power imbalances that they're
they're they're doing to being kind of
weird situations so this is one of the
reasons why I think open source is is
generally
the right approach
and you know I think it's it's a
categorically different question today
when we're not close to Super
intelligence I think there's a good
chance that even once we get closer to
Super intelligence open sourcing Remains
the right approach even though I think
at that point it's a somewhat different
debate
um but I think part of that is that that
is
you know I think one of the best ways to
ensure that the system is as secure and
safe as possible because it's not just
about a lot of people having access to
it it's the scrutiny that that kind of
comes with being with building an open
source system running that this is a
pretty widely accepted thing about open
source is that
um you have the code out there so anyone
can see the vulnerabilities
um anyone can can kind of mess with it
in different ways people can spin off
their own projects and experiment in a
ton of different ways and the net result
of all of that
is that the systems just get hardened
and get to be a lot safer and more
secure so
I think that there's a chance
that that ends up being the way that
this goes to a pretty good chance and
that
having this be open
both leads to a healthier development of
the technology and also leads to a more
balanced
um
distribution of the technology
in a way that that strike me as good
value is to Aspire to so to you the
risks there's risks to open sourcing but
the benefits outweigh the risks at the
two it's interesting I think the way you
put it
you put it well that there's a different
discussion now than when we get closer
to the uh to development of super
intelligence of of the benefits and
risks of uh open sourcing yeah to be
clear I feel quite confident in the
assessment that open sourcing models now
is net positive I think there's a good
argument that in the future it will be
too even as you get closer to Super
intelligence but I've not I'm I
certainly have not decided on that yet
and I think that it becomes a somewhat
more complex set of questions that I
think people will have time to debate
and will also be informed by what
happens between now and then and to make
those decisions we don't have to
necessarily just debate that in theory
right now